[Música]
antes de que inviertas dinero excesivo
en llevarte a todo tu equipo un par de
días hacer dinámicas de team building
esperando que escalar montañas amarrados
de las manos produzca los
comportamientos que tanto necesita tu
organización permíteme contar una
historia una historia que me ayudará a
exponer cuáles son las seis acciones que
he encontrado una y otra vez realizan
los grandes líderes desde hace miles de
años para crear equipos comunidades
fuertes unidas y sobre todo capaces de
permanecer en el tiempo
y créeme hacer dinámicas de team
building no es una de ellas
esta historia se sitúa 10.000 años atrás
donde los primeros seres humanos
estábamos tratando de sobrevivir a un
ambiente prehistórico y muy amenazador
donde nuestro problema más apremiante no
tenía que ver con caídas del internet
juntas interminables o clientes
descontentos sino más bien con preguntas
del tipo seguiré vivo mañana
en este ambiente se encontraba un
personaje llamado hugo y decimos que se
llamaba y no porque existan registros de
su acta de nacimiento sino porque cuando
nació sus papas cavernícolas hicieron
ese sonido al verlo ok
tras perder a sus padres en su juventud
demorados por un león y quedó
desprovisto de protección y seguridad
y de todos los problemas que tenía uno
le ocupaba casi toda su energía
defenderse de los leones que merodeaban
la región y que de hecho le habían
dejado huérfano
para evitar ser devorado por los leones
se valía de cualquier estrategia
esconderse en cuevas pequeñas aumentarse
a la corriente de los ríos o hasta
hacerse el muertito
para defenderse de la amenaza de los
leones era todo un martirio
hasta que un día quien ya empezaba a
desarrollar una capacidad creativa
propia de los homo sapiens tuvo una idea
y si busco a otros individuos como yo
para protegernos juntos contra la
amenaza de los leones y sin mucho que
perder salió a recorrer las colinas de
la zona buscando a otros seres humanos
que necesitan urgentemente defenderse de
los aviones también unámonos para
protegernos de los leones les decía a
otros individuos quienes emocionados se
unían de inmediato a la causa y la idea
de eeuu que empezó a funcionar la
próxima vez que un león se acercó para
intentar atacarlos el grupo de inmediato
se defendió lanzando piedras y palos
todos unidos espantando y alejando a la
bestia hurra dijeron entre más personas
menos leones y con este grito de unión
fue que nació una nueva tribu y por
obvias razones fue designado como líder
de la misma
hago una primer pausa en la historia de
eeuu pues ya puedo compartir las dos
primeras acciones que llevan a cabo los
líderes de las tribus fuertes y unidas
son dos acciones que al implementarlas
le ayudan al grupo a saber cuál es su
razón de ser y cuál debe ser su
motivación acción número uno identificar
la amenaza siempre que surge una amenaza
surge también una tribu para combatirla
los líderes de las grandes tribus
clarifican el villano que justifica el
porqué necesitamos un grupo por ejemplo
decir que trabajas para un banco no
emociona a nadie pero decir que
perteneces a una tribu que combate la
injusticia y la desigualdad financiera
en el mundo la vuelve fascinante
acción 2 clarificar el llamado los
líderes de las grandes tribus declaran
una misión retadora que les deja
totalmente claro a todos los integrantes
porque vale la pena mantenerse unidos
sin claudicar
reunir a tu equipo para repartir tareas
no te hace un líder muy inspirador que
digamos pero convocar a tu tribu para
declarar una misión la de poner un
nombre en la luna en menos de 10 años
después de volver leyenda
sigamos con la historia de eeuu
pasaron varios meses y la tribu se
mantenía unido y protegida hasta que un
día un chamán que parecía poseer
sabiduría generosa visitó a la tribu
los felicito porque han armado un buen
grupo de defensa contra los leones les
dijo
pero todavía los noto cansados
desvelados y muy nerviosos por
protegerse de ellos yo he encontrado una
forma más fácil de lograr el mismo
resultado pero con menos esfuerzo
quieren saber cómo
desde luego que sí comentó book a nombre
de toda la tribu prendan una fogata
luminosa y humeante el fuego no forma
asustan los leones sino que los hace
huir a varios kilómetros de distancia
muchas gracias por tu consejo dijo así
lo haremos y esa misma noche los
integrantes de la aldea se dieron a la
tarea de prender una gran y humeante
fogata
y sucedió justo lo que chama les había
previsto esa noche en ningún león
apareció aquí los demás integrantes de
la tribu estaban felices pues la nueva
técnica del fuego permitió que en la
aldea se vivieron ambiente de menos
estrés y más tranquilidad pero con el
mismo resultado de seguridad
hagamos una segunda pausa pues acabamos
de presentar la tercera acción que
llevan a cabo los líderes de las tribus
fuertes y unidas una que tiene que ver
con ayudar al grupo a tener claridad
sobre cómo se logra el resultado deseado
acción 3 encontrar el fuego los líderes
de las grandes tribus enfocan a sus
miembros explicando cuál es la actividad
relevante para dar resultados esa que
los distingue de otras tribus los vuelve
fuertes y termina por convertirse en su
arma secreta
tener buenos productos te puede generar
clientes pero tener un método o sistema
para crear cada seis meses una
tecnología que revoluciona la forma como
interactuamos con el mundo te genera
fanáticos
y la historia de eeuu podría terminar
aquí pero falta exponer tres acciones
más
pasaron los años y la aldea se mantenía
segura y protegida siempre con el fuego
prendido al centro de la misma aquí los
miembros fundadores de la aldea
crecieron juntos se casaron se hicieron
viejos en ella delegando cada vez más la
tarea de mantener el fuego prendido en
las nuevas generaciones de hijos y
nietos quienes de hecho ya habían
crecido sin nunca haber visto un león
un día uno de los nietos de book a quien
le tocaba vigilar la fogata se le hizo
fácil dejar de prestar atención a su
tarea hay cosas más divertidas que pasar
tiempo echando leña a una fogata dijo y
esa noche el viento de un descuido el
fuego y ésta se apagó que sucedió a
mitad de la noche en la aldea fue
atacada por una manada de leones dando
muerte a varios integrantes de la misma
el nieto de eeuu que entre ellos
lo que ha descubierto el terrible efecto
de una crisis causada por
comportamientos no deseables dentro de
la tribu
tras lamentar y llorar la tragedia
convocó a los miembros fundadores de la
tribu para encontrar una solución este
comportamiento no puede volver a
repetirse jamás dijo necesitamos
encontrar una manera para que la fogata
se mantenga encendida incluso cuando
nosotros ya no estemos presentes en este
mundo de esto depende el futuro de
nuestros nietos y de los nietos de
nuestros nietos
a ver llevarse a la tribu hacer
dinámicas de team building a la montaña
hubiera ayudado desde luego que no lo
que necesitaba implementar sistemas son
métodos que promovieran en todos los
miembros de la tribu comportamientos
ideales pero no sólo un fin de semana
sino todos los días venideros
y fue así que implementó las siguientes
acciones crearemos un ritual del fuego
el cual será un evento que reúna a toda
la aldea y no sólo a unos cuantos a
participar del encendido del fuego del
mismo fuego y para asegurar que prender
el fuego no se vuelve una actividad
monótona y aburrida danzaremos y
cantaremos festivamente alrededor de él
además construiremos un plan de madera
con una figura de fuego en la punta que
nos recordara cada vez que lo veamos que
lo importante del ritual no es danzar y
bailar sino prender el fuego y en tercer
lugar los ancianos debemos transmitir
toda nuestra experiencia a las nuevas
generaciones por lo que reuniremos a los
niños y les contaremos cada noche la
historia de la aldea los leones el
chamán y el fuego
hagamos una última pausa pues ya llegó
el momento de explicar las tres acciones
que acaba de proponer uno reconociendo
sobre todo que nadie vive para siempre
acción número 4 proteger con rituales es
labor de un líder diseñar y formalizar
actividades específicamente creadas para
explicar vivir y proteger la razón de
ser de la tribu y su fuego
tener juntas interminables con tu equipo
para revisar pendientes no es un ritual
y es desesperante pero reunirte con tu
tribu cada domingo para pintarse la cara
quitarse la camiseta y cantar himnos en
un estadio o
te hace sentir que tú también entrenaste
para ser campeón del mundo cierto
acción 5 recordar con símbolos los
grandes líderes utilizan elementos
visuales y palpables para comunicar y
hacer vivido lo que siempre debe ser
recordado depender de un jefe que le
diga a sus colaboradores pónganse la
camiseta no sirve no cambien nada un
comportamiento para entregar una bandera
cantar un himno y reconocer el valor de
alguien poniéndole una insignia en el
hombro que ayude inspirar a toda la
tribu a dar la vida por su aldea literal
y por último acción 6 contar historias
los líderes son grandes contadores de
historias pues saben que para proteger
la mística de su comunidad es necesario
recolectar y transmitir los grandes
relatos que les dieron forma
decir que una comunidad viva el amor
como un principio no dice mucho que
digamos pero decir que existe una tribu
donde desde hace 2000 años se cuenta de
forma recurrente la historia de como su
líder entregó su vida voluntariamente
por el bien de la humanidad puede crear
un antes y un después de esa historia
concluyamos la historia de hugo a partir
de esa noche todos los miembros de la
tribu fueron convocados a participar en
el ritual del encendido del fuego cada
noche junto al tótem de madera convocaba
a los niños para contarles la historia
cambiada de origen a todos les voy a
contar la historia que explica el origen
de nuestro fuego les decía y todos los
niños escuchaban con gran emoción el
ritual diseñado por los demás fundadores
de la tribu era tan claro en explicar el
problema de los leones y el porqué en el
fuego que se sintió de inmediato en
todos los miembros de la aldea un deseo
urgente de proteger a toda costa el
comportamiento vital más importante
mantener la fogata viva
pasó el tiempo yuki los miembros
fundadores de la tribu fallecieron por
causas naturales a la edad no por ser
atacados por un león y hoy se sabe que
en algún lugar del mundo existe todavía
una aldea donde todas las noches se
prende un fuego por convicción se cuenta
la historia de por qué se prende y lo
más importante jamás ha vuelto a ser
atacada por ningún león
estimado líder que te propongo hacer
ahora convoca a tu equipo a tu tribu
cuéntales la historia de eeuu y luego
dediquen dos o tres horas cada semana a
clarificar cómo se deben traducir las
seis acciones en el día a día de su
comunidad identificar una amenaza
clarificar el llamado encontrar el fuego
proteger con rituales recordar con
símbolos y contar historias
estos resultan millones de veces más
efectivo que destinar 50 ó 100 horas a
brincar cuerdas y aventar pelotas
haciendo team building un fin de semana
[Música]